welcome back new technology is taking
the microwave to greater cooking heights
registered dietitian Abby sharp is here
with some delicious and super quick meal
and snack ideas yes right so this isn't
a regular microwave that's right this is
very new we're very excited about this
so unlike traditional microwave
technology which delivers energy in a
linear fashion the cyclonic it's a new
technology that actually dishes out
these spinning rays of power okay you
get a 3d cyclonic kind of energy wave
that ensures the food will cook evenly
and consistently every time right we
were almost talking before we were
saying it's almost like the idea of
cooking with a convection oven where the
the key is tackling around right so it's
it's exactly that way in that sense that
those microwaves are ensuring that you
get the even consistent cooking every
time it doesn't matter what the size or
shape is okay because sometimes with a
conventional microwave stuff in the
middle won't necessarily it'll either be
overdone or done raw exactly so that's
that's the beauty of this and that's why
I've been able to make a whole range of
amazing recipes everything from weekend
entertaining like risotto to family
favorites during the week night like
these amazing chicken sliders you can
cook meals from start to finish it's the
first microwave to actually allow people
to actually cook meals from start to
finish really really healthy and of
course maintain that integrity of the of
the product okay so what are you gonna
make first we're gonna do dessert so I
want to start with dessert so we've got
my tropical fruit crisp but this is
great for those days when people just
drop by unannounced need to whip
something up on the fly so we've got
about a quarter cup each of mango and
pineapple and half a banana here in my
bowl so I'm just gonna get that going
now we're gonna use a little bit of
flour about a half a teaspoon each of
flour a little bit of coconut sugar
coconut sugars lower on the glycemic
index n right traditional sugar so I
really liked that little pinch of nutmeg
some cinnamon I'm gonna do a little bit
of this is my greater here up a little
bit aligns us just to get that on there
and some butter just like half a
teaspoon it's really really not much
there so I'm just gonna mix that in
there that's gonna go into a
microwavable safe dish here so
still have to worry about the you know
making sure everything is microwavable I
mean you just wouldn't want to be
putting anything with like metal or
something we don't want any sparks
flying Oh what that no we don't want
that so just pop that in there really so
simple and we're doing a single serve
portion but you could of course it's a
beautiful size microwave here so you can
do a full full family size as well okay
and then of course the crisp topping
we've got half a teaspoon of flaxseed
high in fiber and protein which I love
got a little bit of coconut for the
tropical aspects just more of a little
bit more of that coconut sugar we've got
a teaspoon of flour and some rolled oats
to make that kind of crisp and then
again I'm just going to add a little bit
of cinnamon and nutmeg and maybe a touch
more of that that greeted lime zest I
love that lime it's comes out fresh it's
so fresh so just mix that up there and
just get that all together and I'm gonna
pop this all on top layer it on like a
nice little crisp right there so this is
going into the microwave two and a half
minutes on high I mean yeah you would
never be able to make a dessert in two
and a half minutes otherwise right in
the oven and i love the electrostatic
last touch control panel on this
microwave this it's you can basically
add timeslide it's like it's a they're
sort of all right we already know and
love that technology so or you can of
course just add the time in 30 second
increments that's another way to do it
so let's just get that going and not
only about can I make amazing desserts
but full meals as well from scratch like
this risotto this is a quinoa kale
risotto he really healthy so fast and
easy I'll never make risotto any other
way right cuz this uses the genius
sensor function and that is unique to
the cyclonic and what it does is it's
programmed in 20 different kinds of
healthy foods things like quinoa oatmeal
omelets soup potato since you want to be
eating more of on a regular basis and it
automatically senses the amount of
moisture in the food and it will figure
out how long to cook so it will stop it
will stop when it's finished okay and
our way it really takes the guesswork
out of it for you and for someone who
you know we're busy where we've got we
live crazy lives then it's back to
school work time so that's another
consideration we've run out of time but
I want to make sure that people know
where they can get these and how much do
they cost definitely so check out Pam
sonic calm for some more information and
of course this is a smaller model this
is 1.6 cubic feet and it goes for 3 99
99 and the larger one is 2.2 cubic feet
and that goes for it for 4999 okay Abby
thanks so much thank you what kind of
Army all right here we're gonna be back
with more warning live right after this
system